Speaker 1: Welcome back to Ye Olde David
Pakman Show. I am Jessy Dallimore sitting
in for David while he is out vanquishing
dum dums on their podcasts. What I want to
talk about is the 2024 campaign for Republican for
the nominee, for the Republican who's going to be
the candidate. And it seems to have been really
supercharged this week with Trump's trips to to
New Hampshire and South Carolina. But there's also
been kind of a tit for tat with with Donald Trump
and the presumed main opponent that he'll face,
Ron DeSantis. And we're going to get a little
history lesson here, and then we're going to play
some modern stuff. But I want you we're going to
go current and then back in time and then back to
current, because just the other day on his on his
what they like to call Air Force One, even though
it's just his personal plane. Donald Trump was
asked in answering questions about Ron DeSantis
and Nikki Haley, the former governor of South
Carolina, his former U.N. ambassador, about their
possible run for president. And he he labeled Ron
DeSantis disloyal. And he said, well, I talked
to her about it. I told her to follow her heart,
but she said she'd never run against her
president, Donald Trump. And then he also got
this job in on Ron DeSantis about his mishandling
of COVID and his when he closed all the beaches,
really taken a shot at DeSantis. And I want
to remind you of that, and then we'll go
back in time a little bit. Watch this.
Speaker 2: Nikki Haley called me the
other day to talk to me. They talked over
a little while, but I said, look, you know,
go buy your heart if you want to run. She's
publicly saying, I would never run against.
My president. He was a great president. Florida
was actually close, very, very close to beaches
and everything. They're trying to rewrite history.
Speaker 1: It is. Wow. It is fantastic. Listening
to Donald Trump whine about Ron DeSantis trying
to rewrite history. These Republican politicians
exist in a in a in an alternate universe where
video cannot be summoned by the Internet and
watched again. Here's Donald Trump, who just just
a handful of years ago during the COVID crisis,
being asked by a reporter about Ron DeSantis
and his performance during the pandemic, the
height of the pandemic. And he is just checking
off just an A-plus A-plus report card for Ron
DeSantis. So the guy who he's now criticizing
for how he handled COVID just just months ago
really was had nothing but praise for the guy.
Speaker 3: As many calls and school districts
are closing across the country.
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis has
not ruled out closing for
opening of schools in May,
saying that many kids are not vulnerable
to this disease. Do you agree with that
assessment? And do you believe that schools
would you recommend that schools open up
and to those states that have it?
Speaker 2: Well, I have a lot of
confidence in Ron DeSantis, a lot of faith in
Ron DeSantis to make the right decision. He's
doing a great job as governor. Ron DeSantis
I had read where he's thinking about opening
up the schools earlier than the date, the end
of the month. I'd have to look at the numbers.
Speaker 1: Got a lot of confidence in Ron DeSantis
checkbook. Got a lot of faith in Ron DeSantis.
Check, Mark. Doing. Doing that. Doing a
great job. Ron DeSantis a plus brother.
Well, Ron DeSantis, obviously just the other
day was asked about this, was asked about this
specific thing about Donald Trump taking them
to task and criticizing him for COVID. And Ron
DeSantis shot I'm actually a little shocked about
it. His response, because he claps right back and
he does it in a real subtle, underhanded dig at
Donald Trump about being a loser in his election.
Watch this. It really does open up the
possibilities for what the Republican stage will
look like during the campaign. Check this out.
Unidentified: Trump has criticized you a number
of times in the past couple of years.
Speaker 4: On a number of different
issues out of hand being told in the state I
just saw. But I would just say, is this ad I
roll out of bed? I have people attacking me from
all angles. It's been happening for many, many
years. And if you look at the good thing about
it, though, is like if you take a crisis situation
like COVID, you know, the good thing about it is
when you're an elected executive, you have to make
all kinds of decisions. You got to steer that
ship. And the good thing is, is that the people
are able to render a judgment on that, whether
they reelect him or not. And I'm happy to say, you
know, in my case, not only did we win reelection,
we won with the highest percentage of the vote
that any Republican governor candidate has in
the history of the state of Florida. We want
by the largest raw vote margin, over
1.5 million votes than any governor
candidate has ever had in Florida history. And
in fact, we almost doubled the previous record,
which I think was like 780,000 vote margin. And
so what I would just say is that verdict has been
rendered by the people of the state of Florida.
Speaker 1: That's dig that is absolutely a dig.
I mean, we'll paraphrase here. It's look, bro,
I won my reelection. What the other guy do,
that's what he's doing here. Now, listen, I'm I'm
one who doesn't believe Ron DeSantis. He's not
ready for prime time. Ron DeSantis isn't ready
to meet Donald Trump on the stage. I think he
will go the way of little Marco Rubio and try his
best to keep up with Donald Trump. But when the
rubber hits the road and when Ron DeSantis has
to face the many insults and the slings and the
arrows that will be delivered by Donald Trump,
he's going to fold like a cheap folding chair.
He's not going to have what it takes. He's not
as slick. He's not as brutal. He is not. He's
not going to be able to withstand what Donald
Trump brings. I think that's the case for just
about every one of these Republicans. You can't
play the nice guy after we've fallen this far,
after the cruelty has been amped up and ramped up
to the level that it has, you're not able to go
back and be a John Kasich. You're not able to be
a mitt Romney. You can't even be a Chris Christie,
for that matter, and win the Republican nomination
for the president of the United States. So we'll
see what takes place. But it is nice to see
that Ron DeSantis isn't just going to lay down
for Donald Trump that there is
going to be a fight because, listen,
a fight among them is good for us. When
these fascists are spending time wasting
time and energy battling one another, that
is time not spent destroying the country